this important report from a daily wire
transgender patients who undergo hormone
therapy have a significantly increased
risk of serious health problems such as
stroke heart attack and Pulmonary
embolism according to a new study a new
study presented at an American College
of Cardiology conference found that
transgender patients who take cross-sex
hormones had an increased risk of
dangerous blood clots that can create
blockages in the brain heart and lungs
the study found the subjects had nearly
seven times the risk of Strokes six
times the risk of the most severe type
of heart attack nearly five times the
risk of pulmonary embolism compared to
those with gender dysphoria who never
used hormone therapy
Dr Ibrahim Ahmed said it's all about
risks and benefits starting
transitioning is a big part of a
person's life and helping them feel more
themselves but hormone replacement
therapy also has a lot of side effects
it's not a risk-free endeavor
who would have thought
who would have thought just injecting
hormones into into someone
to bring their perception
to bring to try to bring their body into
a line with their perception of
themselves
who thought that would have
catastrophic
long-term health effects so everything
we've heard from the media and from the
medical establishment they've been
insisting this for years they've been
telling it to parents and kids and and
patients also who are not uh who are not
kids
they've been saying
it's it's entirely safe it's completely
safe
it's all nonsense
there they are lying
as I've always been saying they they
couldn't even there's no way for them to
know that in the first place
because this is experimental what we're
doing
right now and it's never been done on
this scale anything close to the scale
before in history
and so the people that we're doing it
too now undergoing they're going to go
in the the quote-unquote medical
transition they are the test subjects
so we know to begin with anything they
say about say if it's long-term there's
no way to know that you can't possibly
know that
however we can know again using our
common sense that it's obviously
dangerous to do and there are
consequences anytime you put a a
chemical into somebody's body there are
consequences for it it's never a
consequence so whenever you hear a claim
that's so yeah there's no problem at all
no consequences
that's a huge red flag run the other
direction
because there are always going to be
consequences
okay there are side effects taking
Tylenol there are dangers of taking
Tylenol so and when you're injecting
hormones in yourself of course they're
going to be consequences
obviously it's not a risk-free endeavor
anything close to that
but now since we've been doing this to
people for at a at a Rel at a pretty
large scale for several years now that's
when we're now going to really start to
see so now they have you know they've
got their crop of test subjects and now
we're starting to get the results
and um this is only just the beginning
and it only is going to get worse from
here
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]